go up and this is why modern feminism
creates beta men is that what this video
is all right let's play that
oops the volume gentlemen
no no the top Corner we're gonna have to
probably hit refresh yeah yeah there
there you go right
modern feminism doesn't want women to
fully surrender or submit to a worthy
man AKA Shiva because if she does this
then it forces men to step into his role
as an alpha masculine man and actually
do something Society has discouraged him
from doing that's called taking the lead
which forces the woman to follow his
will and lead and goes against simping
culture which is the backbone of our
economy let me know your thoughts in the
comments below okay let me ask some
questions there's so much to there's so
much to discuss here okay
um a there's the statement that men lead
women follow correct okay so we'll get
your ladies uh opinions on this quote in
itself
um I don't know how many of you ladies
are gonna do what
um Janelle was doing to them
okay so let's start with that Victoria
uh do you know I don't know if this was
like an actual thing that you do in real
life to your man or this is like it is
it is something I do in real life um to
my man is something I encourage we do at
our Retreat so you encourage what women
to to sort of to men whether their
Partners or not if you attend my retreat
you're going to be doing that for sure
to your man to to their man or to a man
that they're doing the exercise with
absolutely wow so a lot of women are
like hell no Janelle correct and this
ain't happening just if they see it like
that now if they attend a retreat and
they understand like the spiritual
component and the polarity component
behind it they understand it it makes
sense okay Victoria
what are the chances Eric we can remove
the like we yeah we don't need all that
um what are the chances that you're
gonna do uh that
the Bowing essentially the kissing of
the feet to your man negative a thousand
like no I'm not gonna happen I'm not
gonna happen okay I'd rather make a
sandwich than I'm more about making
before so you'll make a sandwich yeah
okay that's a good start it's a good
start yeah um but that's just something
why it's just on like the thought of
that is just so not appropriate to you
it's just I'm not your slave like what's
going through your mind
I don't know I'm creeped out a little
bit
listen guys we're having we're having an
open discussion here
nice answer you're a little creeped out
Natalia I know that ain't that kind of
Survivor I personally would not I would
you know make him feel that way in other
ways but I just personally don't feel
like like for me I bow when I pray to
God okay so like I don't like I was
raised like God you know your husband
your you know your kids Etc et cetera et
cetera yeah so I don't feel like I would
want to bow to my husband so that's the
concept
your man is God correct I was raised
that I was raised in in a cult and very
fundamental Christian so I understand
this concept where what what area
um actually I grew up in Thailand my my
family was missionary tattoos yes
um and this is this one is actually
um Sanskrit it says it means surrender
to the Divine and the Divine is who God
oh God but also God my partner now uh do
you believe that God was a man is a man
I believe that God is the divine
feminine energy in masculine and
feminine energy I'm God as well
okay you blew my mind yeah I didn't
catch that okay so when I talked about
polarity yes meaning masculine feminine
energy male and female so Shiva as we
say which is the Divine masculine Cosmic
principle like would you have across
your neck by the way correct yes and
then the feminine version of that is the
Divine uh feminine Cosmic principle
Shakti so it's masculine and feminine
Duality polarity comes together and that
makes Oneness Union and that's the
ultimate when you think about orgasm
that's the ultimate Union
it's when there's no more masculine from
if you're into metaphysics if you
understand like science no or spiritual
science so the metaphysical principle is
the minute you go into orgasm you have
transcended polarity meaning you've
heard of the chakras right of course
yeah you've transcended all of them
because now you're no longer gender
you're no longer male or female you've
gone above that to Consciousness if I
ask you you have the best organism of
your life just go there with me now like
you're there
who said that all right close your eyes
and I ask you what's your name in that
moment of orgasm Eric no you don't know
you don't even know your name you can't
say your name you don't know and the
orgasm the Sexual Energy the orgasmic
energy is the most powerful energy on
the planet just orgasmic energy meaning
that that seed energy there's no it
creates life thank you so if you so what
I do you do that with the right woman
correct I don't I don't need to explain
how sexy I think we got it right how
babies are made all right the store is
not actually a thing Natalia so I teach
people how to master and control that
Sexual Energy for many people it's a
spiritual practice it is for me so when
I look at him that's God that's Shiva
it's a Divine masculine Cosmic principle
of God and he looks at me the same way
as the feminine version of that so to me
to bow to him and it's like I'm bowing
to you because I see in you
a god-like energy and principle of
unchanging unwavering presence so if you
like that clip click right here to watch
another or if you want to watch the
entire saucecast click right here
[Music]